we are officially in the season of love
and valentine's day we'll be here before
we know it so today we are talking all
things flowers cookies cards with our
friend brook fritz of clover and stem
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having me and happy almost
valentine's day i love your heart
sweater you came dressed for the
occasion thank you so much so you never
disappoint whenever you show up this
table is beautiful and it smells amazing
i know it smells amazing right you can't
like i wish everybody could smell it i
know i feel like i'm just in a garden
right now and you know valentine's day
definitely means flowers so let's talk
about some ideas that you have and what
we're gonna make here today so i brought
two kinds of bouquets that i'm gonna
teach you okay one a flower bouquet that
smells delicious and another kind of
flower bouquet made out of cookies oh
okay maybe i like that even better yeah
so first of all i want to say that you
can get all of the things i'm showing
you today from trader joe's it's all
came from trader joe's oh my gosh you
make it easy for us
so first of all i for valentine's day
you don't always have to have red roses
you can have pink and you know purples
whatever you choose but
so to start off doing a bouquet i
arrangement for your valentine's table
or whatever if you want to give it to
somebody and first things first is you
want to always put some flour foam in
your jar and you add a lot of water to
it it soaks it up and something that i
like to do is add filler flour greenery
and then add my flowers next so i have
flowers set up ready for you oh gosh
okay you're making this easy for me i
like it okay
they smell so good okay does placement
matter nope and you know what one thing
i like to do is when you're placing your
florals not to put them all the same
height you want different levels so it
looks pretty oh my gosh this looks so
beautiful so you just buy different
bouquets at trader joe's and trim them
down yeah you can actually buy a bunch
of these mums and a bunch of these roses
and a bunch of the stock flour i love
that and then you can arrange them
however
and i also like this idea is this just a
place mat underneath something fun to
set it on so yeah you know decorate your
house with it as well yeah i'm getting a
little
professional
you're so such a professional thank you
this is so fun oh and just like a little
something else here okay i'm having
i'm feeling it right there yeah it looks
amazing i love the idea of flower
bouquets but now i need to know what is
a cookie bouquet this is the cutest
thing i've ever seen cookie bouquet
something my mom did my mom was
pinterest before pinterest started just
telling everybody right now so we made
cookies bouquets for valentine's day
every year and so the first things first
is these little heart
um jelly beans from trader joe's you're
going to take a skewer okay and you're
going to put the jelly bean
on the skewer okay i am feeling a little
far we're like cupid right now poking
through our hearts we are here's two
cookies for you okay thank you
and you're gonna take two cookies you're
gonna put them together and you're gonna
slide them on top of the skewer oh that
one pushed down a little farther guess
what if you make a mistake you just fix
it or you just eat it you just start
over
oh and then and then you top it off with
another jelly bean on the top oh my gosh
this is such a cute idea and you just
put it in a little vase put in a little
vase and you have a cookie bouquet to
get to anybody you want oh my gosh this
is so funny and this could be perfect
like an activity to do at home with the
kids
and you know or if you don't have kids
you can still do it yeah there's a
close-up of me working very hard on my
cookie bouquet look i kind of did it
you're a talent you're talented all
natural brook this is such a fun idea a
way to make it interactive for the whole
family and just real quick if you had to
say your go-to like flower for
valentine's day i know red rose is a
little simple or basic but what do you
love most
i love most
pinks yes i love pinks for valentine's
and purples that's why i picked this too
but i love pink and i always love to
throw in a little bit of pamphlets i
didn't today but if you go to my
instagram panthus is my thing and that's
what i love you can get pink pampers oh
i've never seen that i know campus are
trending and everyone's doing it for
everything from weddings to party
planning but you got a little bit of
something for everyone here so brooke
thank you so much be sure to go find her
on social media all of her photos are
amazing i'm going to take a little heart
jelly bean you know to end this out so
thank you so much
thank you all right moving on filmmakers
dust off a 48 year old horror classic
and meatloaf hunts for ghosts in his
final role dana bacas has your ion
entertainment report